i'm a musician musician for real i play
instruments you know like i'm really
singing singing for real but i'm really
a fan of hip-hop playpod for real right
i'm really a producer like i produce
giallis and everything i really
really do this there's way more where it
comes from you keep all the money is
what you're saying
make the beat write the song mixed it
mix the record i'm everything damn
you're like the bronx russ
kind of wow
you heard the song that was that rust
dropped no i did not
dropped a joint two weeks ago called
seduce it's going crazy right now number
you know
russ drops a song every week so it's
hard for me to keep up at this point
well he puts a lot of [ __ ] music out
well the seduce one the one that we got
is going stupid right now that's all i
know how did you how did how did the
russ connection happen um he reached out
because he just seen my energy suppose
you're on instagram and everything like
that like just once you tap in you see
how i move
like we kind of was saying he he
produces a lot of his stuff he engineers
a lot of us you know i do the same we
both talk spicy because you understand
when you do it yourself you don't have
to lower your voice your life but no
jokes that aren't funny it's a whole
real energy so with me me to him people
like tori there's certain people that
are just like once we tap in i'm
learning too much from them they're
driving too much jewels it's too far so
once we connected it was it was like
nothing we dropped a joint like a week
after we recorded it and now it's going
stupid